free movement is one of the --use
fundamental principles while border
controls have been abolished within the
Schengen area the EU needs to fight
terrorism cross-border crime and illegal
immigration and make sure as external
borders are protected this is what the
Schengen information system or sis is
about the Schengen information system is
the best tool for police cooperation all
over Europe we want to make it better
the European Parliament now asks for
alerts on children at risk of abduction
and individuals of links to a crime
scene
the extended use of biometrics and more
automatic information sharing between
countries lawmakers also want to make
the return of illegal migrants more
efficient we are creating a new alert in
the system for a turn decision which
means that if somebody is apprehended in
another member state they will know that
in the first Member State there was a
return decision so they can act upon
that instead of starting the whole
procedure from scratch again
strengthening security is crucial to
preserve a free movement in the EU
[Music]